[Music]
today's question comes from rick in
delaware he says i'm 27 years old and
for the most part i follow your
financial advice i only pay for things
with cash or debit however i have over a
hundred thousand dollars of open credit
when stocks crashed earlier this year i
used two of my credit cards to borrow
twenty thousand dollars at zero percent
interest and bought s p index etfs i
thought wow stocks crashed i'll buy now
pocket three to five thousand when the
market bounces back and pay off the
balance
now the etf values are even lower
the total i had in the stock market was
thirty thousand and now i only have
twenty one thousand the zero percent apr
on the cards will end in october of next
year should i pay off my credit cards
now and take a loss of nine thousand
dollars or should i ride the wave until
the loan is over since all the money is
in indexes i have only two thousand
dollars in cash i make thirty five
thousand a year and i have about fifteen
hundred in monthly expenses
a lot of bad decisions were made here
that's why you get the big bucks george
rick sounds like a 27 year old making 35
thousand dollars who thought he was
going to get rich quick
by using credit cards to invest
yeah there's yikes written all over this
but we'll answer his question
proverbs says um
he who hastens
to be rich
will not go unpunished
every time you set yourself up to get
rich quick you can get your head taken
off
um there is no shortcut to any place
it's worth going and so this is the
lesson of this
horrible tale
for this young man and for any of you
listening to this young man's horrible
tale
um
[Music]
so basically you're going to have some
pain
you're just gonna have to choose your
pain
okay
you're going to have the pain of waiting
and risking even more if you ride until
october
it could be down further
and you could be further in the hole
or it could come up
and you might not not have to write a
check for nine thousand nine thousand
dollars is a lot of money when you make
thirty five thousand
however you can make fifteen hundred
dollars a month delivering pizza
or uber eats
and your little butt's about to go to
work to pay for your stupidity my son
uh because i've done the same thing and
that's the only way i got out of it it's
worked my way through it
so when i've done something stupid rick
and i have done a lot of stupid things i
have a phd in do um buddy
so uh when i do something stupid and it
causes me to lose money i call that
stupid tax
and you young men are getting ready to
write a check for stupid tax
the only question is how big the check
is
you can name your poison right now it's
9 000 bucks and call it call it a day
i learned my lesson not playing this
game anymore
over i found usually if it starts with
easy it ends with hard and he was trying
to make an easy 3 000 and now he owes a
hard 9 000
because he wanted to take a shortcut
and try to
gain the system every night when you're
delivering pizza just
go you know
i hate the idea of borrowing money on
credit cards to buy etfs
i hate the money i hate the idea of
borrowing money on credit cards to buy
etfs i hate them i hate the idea of
trying to beat the market with borrowed
money i hate the idea and just by the
time you finish delivering all those
pizzas you will really hate the idea
that card's gonna get cut up yeah
and you'll be done with this what are we
doing giving 27 year olds making 35k a
hundred thousand dollars of open credit
uh we didn't but uh some idiot bank did
uh so but yeah so rick you really have
two options i mean one is limit your
losses to 9 000 or take a chance
um you're going to likely take some
medicine
somewhat less than nine thousand
somewhat more than nine thousand
what is the market going to do between
now and october i do not know
um
i do not know
his track record
i think the market is going to come back
up but i don't know if it's going to
make it by october
i think there's enough negative pushes
on the market that
i don't know if it recovers 100 of your
money by october i
i wouldn't make that bet
i'm not saying i don't know i just don't
know
so if i'm in your shoes and i don't know
what i don't need is more pain i'm
probably going to
i would rather have a known devil than a
future unknown devil
because that 9 000 could turn into 12
000 bucks it could it could turn into
15.
uh before it turns into nothing i mean
it could turn into nothing that's a
positive everything's a possibility here
on the table but so i
i think you're paying nine thousand
dollars
in tuition to the school of life
and you're getting ready to write a
check and graduate with honors
summa [ __ ] laude yup look at that no it's
uh thank you lordy thank you lottie yeah
that's it so um geez yeah i'm sorry
i'm not making fun of you because i'm
i'm readily admitting i've done dumber
things when i was exactly your age crap
i went bankrupt when i was 28.
so with millions of dollars in real
estate debt so
you know
you're a little nine thousand dollars
stupid ain't even close to mine so uh
you know i'm not picking on you i'm not
shaming you but i do want you to realize
and say out loud one of the benefits of
me going bankrupt is i figured out it
doesn't work what doesn't work and i
don't do it again i've done a lot of
stupid things very seldom george have i
done the same stupid thing twice you
learned a lesson i generally find a new
one to do but we touched a hot stove and
went not again but yeah this is so the
goal is to save up the 9000 by october
so you can pay it off no just pay it off
as quickly as you can put on credit card
pay it off now it's on a credit card
right yeah yeah so it's on there it's on
there just cash out your cash out your
stocks today you got nine thousand
dollars left
and or your etf today you got nine
thousand dollars in credit card debt and
because you were stupid and you go
deliver pizzas and pay off your stupid
and work like a maniac and if you can
deliver pizzas 80 hours a week and be
done in three months or two months
that'd be great
but um it's gonna take you a little
while but you you know clean up your
mess and all the while going i learned
my lesson i learned my lesson learned my
lesson i learned my lesson to learn my
lesson
i was about that age when i bought gold
i lost five grand on that gold deal
that was about it because and i had it
all figured out
i was so smart
for a stupid guy
and so what is the mentality behind this
is it this well i'm gonna i'm gonna
outsmart the system i figured it out
yeah there's a let me set it arrogance
every time you fall for get rich quick
it's
um
usually not every time it's almost
always got a level of arrogance to it
like i you know i understand that
there's risk but i am smarter than all
these people who perceive there to be
too much risk because i've got this
figured out
and there's always that that element of
arrogance to your
diving into bitcoin you're diving into
beanie babies
well thank you stuff people put money
into it he's a cautionary tale so he
helped us out today yeah hopefully
stopping another 27 years rick is your
anti-mentor for the day
uh everybody needs an anti-mentor
bless your heart rick i'm sorry man i'm
sorry you're going through this but hey
good news is only nine thousand dollars
good news you're 27 you got the rest of
your life to never do this stupid butt
stuff again